System Shock remastered has seen the
light of day the first gameplay footage
of the reimagined game was released by
developer night dive studios on YouTube
I'm Lucy and welcome to this blast from
the past gamespot news update the system
shock remake is being developed immunity
and the video shows off its new user
interface and visuals night I've says it
will keep the new game true to the
classic experience of course that means
you can still hit monsters with the pipe
after 20 years we are remastering and
reimagining the original system shock we
will keep the new game true to the
classic experience keeping all the
things you loved while updating the user
interface and graphics to use a
modern-day engine you'll be able to play
it for yourself when System Shock
remastered hit xbox one and pc next year
additionally night dive Studios is
currently working on the upcoming System
Shock 3 the studio revealed last year
that it had acquired the rights to the
system shock franchise it was also
recently announced that Deus Ex creator
Warren Spector had joined the team to
work on the game so what do you make of
the look of System Shock remastered do
you like the look at the new graphics or
do the old ones hold a special place in
your heart let me know in the comments
below or come find me on Twitter I'm
Malusi James games for more on System
Shock keep it gamespot
you